to you all my name is Pawel Sarita
well it's very common mistake I'm really
happy that you are all here as numbers
people I should just schedule my topic
is about sound yes and sound is
something that is not so common in in
the space of deep learning in terms of
like common view mostly it's about NLP
mostly it's about images all those
domains are are very interesting but I
would like to introduce you to a brief
look on how to a model sound in a
particular way only as a sound we'll see
later
so my general agenda is very simple one
and I would like to you to just pick
some general ideas and about sound
representation and also how to how to
use Python how to use some number of
libraries to to represent to encode
those sounds and then use that into
other machine learning algorithms for
particular purposes like classification
extraction etc however my general heart
is in music creation and soundscape
sounds art world so I will show you how
to make sound by computers nowadays and
I hope you will sometime take some time
and maybe show it to your kids whenever
they will grow up okay so who I am my
name is Paulo Street I'm a research
engineer in various companies I have
like 15 years in different domains I was
working on as voice now about Bigsby
speech synthesizers in Samsung I was
doing speaking speech and speaker
recognition in couple of companies and
also I was lecturing sound engineers and
composite composite composers in here in
Warsaw University of music music
University as as my artistic background
is I was introduced to to that around
2009 and I was bringing up a lot of
people around new technologies and how
you can shape those creating various
music controllers also in Python here
when we are here in kaepernick in 2015
there was a sound installation during
the summer like six during six weekends
based on some parts was in Python most
was in super collider is a very bizarre
a synchronous language only specific to
sound generation and it was a mixture of
all possible things like taking data and
so defied that so analyzing clustering
those data that we're coming out from
trains from from buses of a war so and
also sampling and recordings all
different parts of war so and then using
for example granular synthesis I will
not you can check it out what is in just
to change the sound and also to
orchestrate the whole piece on those
boxes there were different sensors like
haptics ones like sonic
there were also cameras there were also
different microphones and different
pickups so whatever their words and the
box for example like screws like were
recorded but also those things trigger
the sound in the coal piece so but
that's about me let's start about
sound so when we want to have a sound we
need to have some kind of tool
instrument and mostly is about guitar
and different kind of blocks that's the
analog electronic world what is called
an analog but I know like I would say
that it's just like acoustic just
acoustic guitar and that's any any
without wires so but people are really
into like taking any objects hitting it
or doing whatever and then record it and
later on you can sequence that you can
group that you can mix that into a piece
that later one will be ported out as a
cassette or CD or other file medium into
some kind of distribution and listener
it's a whole different idea to talk
about how different is the process how
it changed throughout the years
right now the process is so simple you
can mix record edit a little bit master
you have file and then directly you send
the file to Spotify Deezer you name it
and they just and they use their own
mastering device algorithms to enhance
the sound and put them into their
collection so you really cannot really
have a control over your piece how it
will be listened to
that's why I like live performance and
of course you can use adapt or you can
use you cannot hear it
where's wait a second
hmm so this is a excel file that's
changed into sequencer sequence is a
very simple way of representing of music
you have beats and you can have on the
rows you have instruments and then on
the time you select where it will be
played and you can do it whatever and
this this way of this kind of software
was done by old people like
do-it-yourself in 80s and by they're
owned by an Atari in the program and
their by their own right now you
generally have those kind of big digital
audio workstation when you don't know
what what is inside of it and of course
you can even use some I'll just put a
portion of it I don't know whether it
will render you can of course use a
position or some kind of interactive
tools with what is called graphical
programming visual programming languages
with a lot of friends omnis there are
ideas on generative algorithm and just
simply generate the piece soundscape yes
this will be so this is a few data is an
open source environment a graphical
environment that can be controlled from
PI Python as well those blocks are just
some kind of functional blocks never
nevertheless you see that those scripts
this is a program a program for people
that don't really know how to program
graphically like creative people are
taught during studies for this kind of
machine this kind of language just
enhance their possibility there there
are different tools they can create
their own tools they can create their
own environment when they just have
like like you would just set up the the
whole workstation when you all have the
scripts and all ready to to render they
also can create those kind of scripting
environment and in fact most of the
goods and known studios or composers
they started order right now using such
tools like enhanced Zimmerman he had on
the start he had max/msp right now he
has six programmers only for him just to
make all those kind of little thing
things as orchestration as a tools for
for creation and just where this broad
is bringing us that right now with the
deep neural networks of course Gans and
algorithms that are that are give us
possibility to render whatever we like
from text to image to sound this is a
pure synthetic artist Yano that is just
like two weeks ago just started to have
their own premiere on Spotify but this
is not a new thing this is just a hyper
hype hype on the USA because in Japan
that was 20 years ago with Vocaloid
which is kind of sorry the technology
[Music]
for good the artist nevertheless this
artist and a couple of others are
virtual artists and they have even live
performance when there are streams into
the screen and the voice the music is
either synthetically creates upfront or
just you know created live and this this
technology was 2010 when it was really
good it started in around 2000 yes so
mine my my
message to use that's if you are already
if you're not creating right thousand
just started if you if you really use a
guitar keyboard or whatever you you
already been using try to think to
expand enhance your workspace and use
whatever tool is is there Python or pure
data or just in in order not to expand
your your point of view and innovate on
the art form because the dnw
really shape the music into this third
three minutes 30 seconds and right now
even two minutes 15 seconds pieces
that's you know the the music pieces on
Spotify right now have starts with a
chorus because people just listen to
chorus okay is good and then then the
the whole part begins like after 10
seconds so the general purpose of the
computer for music and sound production
is to be a creative enhancement and to
assist assist I mean when you generate
music based it's not to just produce
absolute solution but assist you so you
are a curator for your data as you
Creator to your data you are curator for
the result that is generated you pick up
you generate multiple times of very
various conditions whatever and you pick
the best one this is one of the flows
that you workflows that you can follow
but yeah let's dip dive so basic concept
if you don't know what is the sound I
could speak like at least three hours
this is generally a physics so you see
the the two particles of the air moving
off if you digitalize you can have
different dots so values per micro
seconds and then you can traverse it
into frequency domain into frequency
representation that is on the
left-up corner and if you want to really
plot that as an image so fruit time you
can have spectrogram and this is basic
thing that people are using using in
deep learning so using sound visual or
presentation of a sound through time and
you can you know if you want to have a
very simple classifier you can put this
image into ResNet or vgg net or whatever
and have a simple already trained or
pre-trained vgg on imagenet or whatever
and have a very good decent classifier
of i don't know
I want this classifier for lips max for
for sound to analyze to clean up the
data set of speech recordings and then
you can just throughout this and
normally I just sound engineer would
spend like a week cutting out on the NW
all those lips Max and if you can just
have this simple analyzers and knowing
where those are places you can either
then manually review that or just have a
simple Python script that's just remove
that block and saves the file lit for
later
all right so but if you want to have a
sound you need to have basic equation of
a sound which is sinusoid that can be
created in and playback in Python but
those parameters are most of the
instrument sound it's ember pitch and
dynamics and this what a MIDI sends to
to the MIDI controller or keyboard or
whatever instrument MIDI instrument
there is since do some kind of sounds
synthesis devices you can also create
with there is a possibility to create
using if you know what are the way of
excavations of a from physics if you
just skip the physics books on sound
creation you can find some equation put
into the function called dump wave for
example and some it's already in the
library called wave bender you can just
synthesize harmonics of particular sound
of a sound of violin and have that
already available to sound is not so
good as standard one so however the
general case is that if you analyze
music or sounds you need to see it as a
sequence model is an event based or
sequence based domain machine problem
and mostly it can be described and is
described in the kind of physics
mathematical equation but let's let's
put it that commonly the music
production software companies and also
the the studios are so into the very
good quality of sound that's why they
mostly they just use the software that's
played back simple samples of sound into
like six three six recording of a
particular note on an instrument put it
in the software packages and expand that
you can of course use right now it's
very common
come on in some pop music and also rap
music for for for samples like bass
parts to use FM synthesis I will not
cover that but the advance is also kind
of signal processing algorithms and what
I wanted to talk about is about
parametric models which is a model that
will shapes that have Jarrell I some
idea of of a sound of a model and have
parameters to it and in order to to
grabs the interior of the model someone
put it the knowledge upfront or use
features
as a rule grew light to transverse the
sound model one of this is very simple
sound source source filter model so we
assume that there is a sinusoid or a
noise from for example from your glottal
or from the string string string is very
common since i dial but there is a
little noise in it from when stamping
and when is dumping also it changes some
frequency characteristics so that's why
you put general filters on the frequency
domain and change the timbre of the
sound and that's that in this simple way
you can create a certain timbre also you
can have this taken this FF the sound
wave form into frequency domain and
analyzing it word are the components
where are this most high energy parts
which are probably synthesized because
you were analyzing that for like 20
years all most of the speech speech
codecs that were in GSM 1 2 & 3
use variant right now also some parts of
your Bluetooth very bad connection also
use this kind of model that it's
searching for most high frequency parts
assume that it is synthoid and and the
rest and ala is what is the rest but and
create a model stochastic model of of
the noise and that glue its together
this is a diagram of the of this since I
have time is passing you see that most
of the things is about signal processing
and and recreation of a sound as a parts
of the harmonics of the sinusoid and the
noise there is a tool very good so made
from people from Yamaha that's used the
software is also used by
in the Yamaha synthesizers it's called
SMS tools an SMS call since old modeling
software which you can just recreate
review and like do analysis of a sound
you can change some of the
representation in frequency so example
for example you can change the value of
certain formats and then recent designs
or put a filter on it and reset the size
and this way you can shape the sound of
a violin in certain way you can for
example
you never hear the violin with the third
formant moved into up high or something
you can shift the the the timbre because
I didn't tell that the timbre of a sound
is the caresses of the timbre of a sound
is the way how the harmonics are what
are the frequency of certain harmonious
and what are the amplitude of that so
when you change that you generally
change the whole timbre all sound of the
particular note but yeah people like in
2010 or 2005 ten already you have that
model and they wanted to make the sound
better so they started to use much more
and more machine learning more in more
statistical model in order to optimize
to find it to fine tune the parameters
most of those parameters for like you
would like to create violin synthetizer
let's say right you can of course sample
that but you can also make generator
like this in synthesis like this using
this technique why because it will be so
small the model will be so small that
you can put it into very little shape
and sell it in the millions like Emma
how or Cassio or whatever and if you
tune the parameters in various
conditions then you can shape the sound
as well you can put number of knobs as a
controlling
parameters into the model yeah and one
of the that is for speech if you don't
use SMS library you can use world speech
model which is a continuation of
straight very very good speech
synthesizer model the representation of
a model of the speech and the model
generally analyzed where's where are the
the pitch components the form the where
is the pitch what is the pitch was what
are the four months what are the
harmonics and then extracts with this
information the the stochastic model of
of the noise floor yeah but what about
neural models one of the models that is
so often brought up is a wave net and
people from magenta project from Google
they they invited a number of artists of
media artists some kind of researchers
to collaborate them on creating using
the wave net as as a tool for synthesis
modeling the sound so four different
ways so for example you can there is a
typical node but here you can play with
it I will later this presentation will
be available you can generally the model
was trained on all possible instruments
like thousands of instruments and you
can dream using parameters of Latin
variables that you put this model is can
was trained on conditioning on some
variables and changing that you can
change what is the sound between violin
and piano what is the sound with between
voice and saxophone you can do with this
with the first model the general
presentation here is a delegated
convolutions that are later on process
into some kind of distribution around
values of the of the samples there is
magenta project as I said and it's very
well documented there are lots of
examples and here's one one of the two
too and encode the sound you can then
synthesize that and also if you want you
can change the there are in the jupiter
not boot there is a examples how to
shift some some parameters in order to
find the right sound recently there is a
also by the same group there is again
synth again already heard about that the
differences is that there is a you can
generally the the samples from the
generators are taken from specific like
spherical gaussians not normal Gaussian
representation and also that it's it
goes through various convolution layers
with some resonate connections on both
on the same on this generator and
discriminator and found they found out
that if you analyze for very short
periods of time like instantaneous
frequency which is a 1 millisecond
generally the frequency components like
it's doing the same like since the
modeling it's fine find out that there
are some kind of strips around that and
but however it also
and gives you all those Latins variables
to tune the model for particular sound
and as as previously you can take the
code and and play with it
it's briefly quite simple one but you
you probably also want to do something
with recording sound and recording sound
is tricky because it's recorded and you
cannot really change the changes you can
filter out
you can delete some portion but you
cannot really unmix the sound so if you
there are like three components of the
sound like three guitar bass and and
piano you cannot really split up it's
already done but there are two recently
this year and just last year there are
two project that's you can use to to
just take your drum patterns from your
best artists of course it's it's
copyrighted
probably in some part but you can sample
it you can use it in some kind of
hip-hop or or at least put it senses
into analyzer to analyze the beats and
have the same MIDI representation of the
beats and answers on a DW and synthetize
that again generally this is U units
architecture with various convolutions
and BLS the end there is also a splitter
from Deezer a little bit worse but it
depends on what the bass is a little bit
better but the voice is worse than
unmixed
and yeah this is a kind of Holy Grail
form many peoples from like 20 30 years
to so if you like to listen to our chest
raw or like you want to really reflect
on some particular portion on this
particular instrument like you really
like this bass player and
the mix is so dense that you cannot
really listen to it but here you are
it's is there in spite on and you can
also synthetize this voice if you like
there is a Mellotron from nvidia group
generally based on the attacker tron
representations which is encoding of
characters through convolutions
through some LSD ms back to some tricks
in on the apple into mel spectrogram and
the main spoken is put it into wavelets
vocoder and create the sound if you
condition that on the particular style
of playing or particular instrument
there you have it I will leave you up
with some couple of papers and also is
there any questions then thank you very
much
[Applause]